[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to Chicago the Windy City in the
sight of some of the greatest modern
architecture in the world today we're
here to talk about Ludwig Mies van der
Rohe a founding father of modernism and
a towering giant in architectural
history in his work there is a classical
sense of proportion scale and order but
without any ornament decoration or
flourishes using materials like glass
steel or marble his buildings are strong
they're muscular they're brutal and they
have never been more revered than they
are today
this is crown Hall the architecture
school at the Illinois Institute of
Technology mace used to be the director
here and some say it is his greatest
building a twenty six thousand square
feet from old seems to float above the
lawn it has four huge trusses that are
reachable by the waterfall of marble
steps the main floor of this masterpiece
is a large and column-free classroom it
features a suspended roof in a totally
open floor plan that can be adapted to
any use at all when you're in here you
start to understand the concept the
meaning of universal space which is a
term coined by Mies van der Rohe to
describe the flexibility of the spaces
how you can transform or adapt or model
a specific space into whatever
requirement you need and until this day
the students come here they use this
space and they follow the curriculum
that means creative so this space is
alive you see the lines you see the
severity but it's actually the opposite
to severity it has to do with
flexibility
as you may notice this small building is
a little bit different it is a cube
instead of a big pavilion it has brick
walls rather than steel frame it's
called the car memorial chapel but
students around here call it the God box
[Music]
this chapel was built in 1952 and it is
actually the only ecclesiastical space
ever designed by Mies van der Rohe it
bursts almost no resemblance to a
Renaissance or Gothic cathedral instead
it is a temple to God into modernism
inside the guard Box remains stark and
simple this is Miss wanted it steel
railings a marble altar a curtain and of
course across services are still held
here every Sunday
Mies once said too often we think about
architecture in terms of the spectacular
there is nothing spectacular about this
chapel it was not meant to be
spectacular it was meant to be simple
and in fact it is simple but in its
simplicity it is not primitive but noble
and in its smallness it is great in fact
monumental
[Music]
one of the things that I love the most
about Miss Vonda Rose work here at IIT
if there is a school it's not a museum
it's not a shrine it's a place where
people come to learn to study to become
the next generation of architects that
may go off and change the world with
what they build miss van der rote has
buried a few miles from here
at Chicago's Graceland Cemetery and I
really hope that makes him proud
[Music]